est-ce que vous avez vu ces vidéos de
personnes qui utilisent la biafine comme
crème miracle son utilisation
quotidienne et pourtant risqué voici
pourquoi sur tik tok des américaines
vante les mérites de la french team
caire et se ruent dans les pharmacies
françaises pour acheter de la biafine en
effet la crème que l'on trouve à 6 euros
un peu partout en france est bien plus
chère aux états unis où elle coûte 42
dollars la biafine et normalement
plébiscité en cas de brûlures
superficielles comme les coups de soleil
ou pour le traitement d'érythème
secondaire soit des rougeurs sa
composition n'est alors pas du tout
approprié à un usage quotidien elle
contient 16 ingrédients ça fait beaucoup
trop d'ingrédients pour n'avoir que des
aspects bénéfiques actif principal qui
est très apaisant l'euro lamine certes
cet actif peut réagir avec
l'environnement extérieur et cette
réaction chimique d'antan peut former
des groupes qui s'appelle les
nitrosamines et c'est elle qui peuvent
être considérés comme cancérigènes
l'utilisation de la biafine au quotidien
est donc clairement déconseillé